hay prácticamente unanimidad entre los
analistas políticos y los periodistas
brasileños que han comentado en las
redes sociales el último debate entre
Jair bolsonaro y Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva Lula sería el ganador ha tenido un
buen desempeño en todos los bloques del
debate se ha mostrado seguro de sí
atacado y mucho a bolsonado pero casi
siempre con argumentos intentando o bien
mostrar
incongruencias en su gestión o delatar
su falta de conocimiento por ejemplo en
temas económicos hemos visto bolsonaro
bastante nervioso levantando la voz en
más de una ocasión ha habido momento que
casi ha perdido el equilibrio sea
tambaleado pero hay que decir que
bolsonaro ha mejorado con respecto a los
primeros debates y en general con
respecto a toda su trayectoria política
se nota que ambos han pasado por un duro
entrenamiento ha habido En todo caso el
típico cruce de acusaciones
cada uno de los candidatos ha tildado al
otro de ser mentiroso habido momentos
tensos pero también se ha hablado de
varios asuntos como la salud el aborto
la creación de empleo o el medio
ambiente y la preservación de la
amazonia en más de una ocasión Lula ha
intentado hablar del futuro y traer el
debate a los programas de gobierno para
salirse de esta dinámica de
descalificaciones que parece haberse
convertido en la tónica general de los
debates de esta campaña electoral que
está llegando a su fin ya no queda más
margen para convencer a los indecisos el
domingo sabremos Quién es el próximo
presidente de